WE'LL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THAT,
ED, THANK YOU.
AFTER TWO LONG YEARS HERE WE
ARE, HARD TO BELIEVE ANY OF IT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED LOOKING BACK.
IT WAS TWO YEARS OF UNREMITTING,
NEVER DIMINISHING HYSTERIA ABOUT
RUSSIA, CONTINUOUS WAVE OF PANIC
AND SUPERSTITION OVER UNSEEN
SLAVIC INTERFERENCE STOKED BY
THE VERY PEOPLE WE'RE TOLD ARE
THE MOST RATIONAL IN OUR
SOCIETY.
FOR TWO YEARS OUR CAPITAL CITY
BECAME A MASSIVE CNN PANEL, A
LIVING MONUMENT TO IGNORANCE AND
DISHONESTY WITH THE LOUDEST AND
DUMBEST GETTING THE MOST
ATTENTION.
WE JUST LIVED THROUGH TWO FULL
YEARS OF THAT.
SCREAMING, THREATENING, SURVEI
SURVEILLANCE, CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION, LOYALTY, BETRAYAL
FROM OFFICE HOLDERS.
PEOPLE FIND THEMSELVES AFRAID TO
GO TO DINNER.
SCARED TO SEND TEXT MESSAGES OR
TALK ON THE PHONE.
FOR TWO YEARS WE LIVED IN AN ALL
PERVASIVE CULT OF PERSONALITY,
OUR LEADERS WORSHIPPED THE
74-YEAR-OLD FEDERAL PROSECUTOR
WHO ALMOST NEVER SPOKE IN
PUBLIC.
HE ALONE WAS GOOD, THEY TOLD US.
ONLY THEY COULD INTERPRET HIS
WILL.
IT WAS ALL THOROUGHLY BIZARRE.
DEMENTED, THOUGH NOBODY SAID SO
AT THE TIME, THEY WERE TOO
AFRAID.
SEEMS LIKE A DREAM NOW, WHICH
ACTUALLY IT WAS.
NONE OF IT WAS REAL.
NOBODY COLLUDED WITH VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
NOBODY CHANGED VOTE TOTALS OR
MET SECRETLY IN FLAG OR HAD A
PEA TAPE, WHATEVER THAT IS.
THERE WAS NEVER A RUSSIA
CONSPIRACY.
HILLARY CLINTON WASN'T ROBBED OF
HER RIGHTFUL POI BY JULIAN
ASSANGE OR ROGER STONE OR ANYONE
ELSE.
HILLARY LOST THE ELECTION, SHE
WAS AN ENTITLED BOOR WHO DIDN'T
RUN ON ANYTHING.
IN THE END THAT'S WHAT ROBERT
MUELLER PROVED.
THE NEWS ANCHORS COULDN'T HAND
THAT WILL CONCLUSION.
IT WAS TOO FAR FROM WHAT THEY
PROMISED THEIR AUDIENCES FOR SO
LONG.
THEY WERE TOO INVESTED IN THE
LIES.
WHEN THE REPORT ARRIVED IN
CONGRESS THIS MORNING THEY FOUND
THEMSELVES REDUCED TO HUFFING
AND SPUTTERING.
THEY COULDN'T ADMIT WHAT WAS IN
THE REPORT.
WELL, THEY TOLD US, ROBERT
MUELLER DIDN'T EXONERATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
OKAY, I MEAN THAT MAY BE TRUE.
BUT ONLY THEE LOGICALLY -- THEE
ON LOGICALLY.
MUELLER DOESN'T HAVE THE POWER
TO ABSOLVE SIN N EVERY OTHER
SENSE MUELLER'S REPORT WAS
EXCULPATORY.
IF DOZENS OF FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
SPENT TWO YEARS TRYING TO CHARGE
YOU WITH A CRIME AND THEN FOUND
THEY COULDN'T, IT WOULD MEAN
THERE WASN'T ANY REAL EVIDENCE
YOU DID IT.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
YOU MAY NOT LIKE DONALD TRUMP,
BUT THAT'S WHAT WE JUST LEARNED
FROM THE MUELLER REPORT.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE A MINDLESS
PARTISAN TO DENY IT A LOT OF
NEWS ANCHORS TURN OUT TO BE
MINDLESS PAR DAY TY SANS.
WHEN THE FACTS -- PARTISANS.
WHEN THE FACTS CON TO CONVENIENT
THEIR PARTY -- CON TO VEIN THEIR
PARTY THEY PERSIST.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO LIED TO YOU,
FOR TWO YEARS ABOUT RUSSIA,
DEMAND UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE YOU ALLOWED TO BELIEVE
ANYTHING THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BILL BARR MIGHT SAY.
SURE, BARR MAY LOOK LIKE A
CONVENTIONAL REPUBLICAN, HE WAS
A JEB BUSH DONOR AND EVERYTHING.
HE DOES APPEAR TO BE A CLOSE
PERSONAL FRIEND OF ROBERT
MUELLER'S.
BUT THAT'S WHY HE'S SO TRICKY.
IT'S ALL A RUSE.
IN FACT, BARR IS A PUTIN STOOGE
LIKE ALL THE REST.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT HIS BEHAVIOR,
IT IS NOT THAT OF A JER EE AT
TRICK, IT IS -- GERIATRIC, IT IS
A PARTISAN.
>> THIS IS AN INSIDE JOB.
SHOULDN'T TAKE ANYTHING BARR
SAYS.
>> IS BARR THE PRESIDENT'S NEW
FIXER?
THE ANSWER SEEMS TO BE YES.
>> HE BECOMES THE FIRST CABINET
SECRETARY TO PLUNGE INTO THE
DEEP END OF TRUMP'S CONSPIRACY
POOL.
>> Tucker: IT WAS AN INSIDE JOB.
THAT'S THE ASSUMPTION IN
WASHINGTON.
SOMEHOW, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
PREVENTING ROBERT MUELLER FROM
CONCLUDING THAT DONALD TRUMP
COLLUDED WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN.
AND FROM TELLING THE REST OF US
ABOUT IT.
HOW IS BARR DOING THAT?
WELL IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW HE'S
DOING.
THAT BUT THEY ARE CERTAIN HE IS
DOING THAT.
THEY ANNOUNCED THIS MORNING, IT
MARKED AMERICA'S TRANSFORMATION
INTO AN AUTHORITARIAN JUNTA.
A COLLEAGUE AT THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" SUGGESTED THAT TRUMP
MIGHT BE A NAZI, THE WHITE HOUSE
PLAYED A SONG FROM THE SOUND OF
MUSIC, WHICH BY THE WAY IS AN
ANTI-NAZI MUSICAL.
BUT IT'S SUSPICIOUS.
THESE ARE HYSTERICAL CHILDREN.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE IN
JOURNALISM.
BUT THEY ARE.
IN FACT THEY RUN JOURNALISM AND
THEY HAVE NO PLANS ON GIVING UP
THEIR POWER.
THE MUELLER REPORT IS PROBABLY
THE SINGLE MOST HUMILIATING
THING THAT HAS EVER HAPPENED TO
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS IN
THE HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
HOW DID REPORTERS IN WASHINGTON
RESPOND TODAY WHEN IT FINALLY
CAME OUT?
WELL THEY DID WHAT THEY DO BEST,
THEY CELEBRATED THEMSELVES.
OVER ON CNN, FORMER OBAMA
OFFICIAL POSING AS A REPORTER,
SAID THE MUELLER REPORT DEBUNKED
ALL OF DONALD TRUMP'S UNFAIR
ATTACKS ON THE MEDIA.
JEFF BEZOS' NEWSPAPER SAID THE
VAST AMOUNT OF REPORTING ON
RUSSIA WAS ACCURATE.
UH-HUH.
EVEN THOUGH DON'T REALLY BELIEVE
THIS.
THEY KNOW THEY LIED.
BUZZFEED CLAIMED ITS REPORTERS
HAD SEEN WITH THEIR OWN EYES
THAEFT MICHAEL COHEN WAS
INSTRUCTED BY DONALD TRUMP
HIMSELF TO PERJURE HIMSELF.
THIS WAS GOING TO BE GROUNDS FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
BUZZFEED DEFENDED THAT STORY
EVEN AFTER THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION TOOK THE UNUSUAL
STEP OF PUBLICLY SAYING IT
WASN'T TRUE.
BUZZFEED WENT ALL IN, THEY
DEFENDED IT, SEEN WITH THEIR OWN
EYES.
HE TOLD US THAT ON THIS SET ON
THIS SHOW.
NOW THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT.
IT'S OVER, IT'S DONE, A LIE.
THAT AND SO MUCH MORE, ALL LIES.
SO, WHAT HAPPENS NOW THAT WE
KNOW THOSE WERE LIES?
WHAT DO WE DO WITH JOHN BRENNAN
AND JAMES CLAPPER.
THEY USED TO RUN THE MOST
POWERFUL INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
THEY'VE GOTTEN A LOT RICHER THAN
THEY'VE EVER BEEN FROM YAPPING
ABOUT RUSSIA ON TELEVISION.
ONLY PROBLEM, ALL LIES.
>> WHAT MAKES YOU BELIEVE THAT
HE HAS MORE INDICTMENTS?
>> BECAUSE HE HASN'T ADDRESSED
THE ISSUES RELATED TO CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY AS WELL AS ANY
INDIVIDUAL --
>> CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY INVOLVING
RUSSIANS?
>> YES.
>> IS THERE INFLUENCE WHETHER
WITTING OR UNWITTING BY THE
RUSSIANS OVER PRESIDENT TRUMP,
AND YOU KNOW, IN THE INTERVENING
YEAR AND A HALF OR SO, HIS
BEHAVIOR HASN'T DONE MUCH, AT
LEAST IN MY MIND, TO ALLAY THAT
CONCERN.
>> Tucker: DO CLAPPER AND
BRENNAN GET TO KEEP THEIR CABLE
TELEVISION KRGTS?
PROBABLY.
IN DECADENT SOCIETIES THE GUILTY
AREN'T PUNISHED, ONLY THE
UNPOPULAR.
ON THE OTHER CHANCE THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT TRUMP TONIGHT, OF
COURSE, NOT THEMSELVES OR THEIR
FAILURES.
THE LINE FRIDAYS TODAY'S REPORT,
TRUMP'S RESPONSE WHEN HE FIRST
LEARNED THERE WAS GOING TO BE A
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION
INTO RUSSIA.
OH, GOD, HE SAID, THIS IS
TERRIBLE.
THIS IS THE END OF MY
PRESIDENCY.
I'M F 'ED.
MUELLER DIDN'T DRIVE HIM FROM
OFFICE, IT WASN'T THE END OF HIS
PRESIDENCY STRICTLY SPEAKING.
AS USUAL TRUMP'S INSTINCTS WERE
CLEARER, THEY WERE DEAD ON.
IN THE WAYS THAT MATTER MOST,
THE RUSSIA HOAX DID END HIS
PRESIDENCY IN SOME SENSE.
IT CERTAINLY SABOTAGED IT.
MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION ENDED
CRITICAL MOMENTUM FROM THE 2016
ELECTION ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
MOMENTUM THAT EVERY INCOMING
PRESIDENT USES TO GET YOUR
PROGRAM ENACTED, MAKE GOOD ON
THE PROMISES YOU JUST MADE TO
VOTERS.
TRUMP DIDN'T HAVE THAT, THANKS
TO RUSSIA.
LAWMAKERS, INCLUDING SHAMEFULLY
LARGE NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS WE
SHOULD NAME BUT WE'RE OUT OF
TIME BUT WE WILL AT SOME POINT,
WERE HAPPIER TO TALK ABOUT
RUSSIA THAN ABOUT CHANGING THE
STATUS QUO IN WASHINGTON.
SOMETHING THEY WERE BENEFITTING
FROM, BUT TRUMP RAN AGAINST.
SO THEY DID TALK ABOUT RUSSIA.
ENDLESSLY.
THE RESULT, AN ELECTION THAT
SHOULD HAVE REALIGNED A
POLITICAL PROCESS AND CHANGE
THIS COUNTRY HAD ALMOST NO
EFFECT.
TWO YEARS LATER, VIRTUALLY
NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
MILLIONS ARE STILL FLOODING OVER
THE BORDER FROM THE THIRD WORLD,
ENCOURAGED BY AN ARMY OF
NONPROFITS MOCKING OUR LAWS.
THE OPIOD EPIDEMIC RAGES ON AS
HORRIFYING AND DESTRUCTIVE AS
EVER.
SUICIDES ARE UP.
TROOPS ARE STILL BOGGED DOWN IN
SYRIA AND AFGHANISTAN AND MANY
OTHER PLACES.
GOLDMAN SACHS CONTROLS OUR
ECONOMY.
TECH COMPANIES ARE SPYING ON
YOU.
CRUSHING YOUR FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
YOU CAN HAVE YOUR LIFE RUINED
FOR SUPPORTING THE WRONG
CANDIDATE IN PUBLIC OR BELIEVING
THERE ARE TWO GENDERS.
MOST OMINOUS OF ALL AND MOST
OFTEN IGNORED, AMERICANS ARE
DYING YOUNGER AND HAVING FEWER
CHILDREN.
NONE THIS WAS EVER RESOLVED,